i'm gonna give you a bunch of facts in a
row and people are gonna get really
uncomfortable
they're gonna feel really difficult
about this stuff because here's the
reality
if you base your opinion on the fact
this may this may force you
to come to some conclusions you wish you
didn't have to come to
according to pew research the net worth
of white families in 2013 was 141 000.
for black families it was eleven
thousand even less than the nineteen
thousand
it was in two thousand seven according
to economist edward wolf of the
university of new york
excluding vehicles and other durables
the median black family worth
is just seventeen hundred dollars while
forty percent of black families have
zero or negative wealth
white family worth in terms of financial
worth
is 69 times more than that of black
families
given this disparity how can you argue
that
racism is not a driving factor in income
inequality because it has nothing to do
with race and everything to do with
culture and when you have a culture that
doesn't
and when and when you know what explain
to me you explain to me why black kids
aren't graduating high school
explain that one to me explain to me why
black kids are shooting each other in
rates significantly higher
than whites are shooting each other
explain why 13 percent of the population
is responsible for 50 percent of the
murder explain to me
why they why the number of blacks black
kids in prison not for
innocent reasons not for walking down
the street getting pulled into a prison
is so high
explain if it has nothing to do with
culture explain to me why the single
motherhood rate in the black community
jumped from 20 to 70 percent in the same
course of time that the civil rights
movement
has made such tremendous strides is
america more racist now than it was in
1960 and if it is please explain to me
how that happened
it's more than just riots right i hate
the idea when you say
thugs and riots right white people riot
as well
when y'all win super bowls two years in
a row y'all get off the hook don't make
it seem like it's just baltimore getting
upset
so my 32nd answer is i
feel the frustration of what's happening
in the community and i think it's a
symptom the the uprisings are a symptom
of a pressure that's been unaddressed
for too long
i'm offended by the language of uprising
applied to people who are breaking into
other black people's stores and looting
them
uh this is not this is a lack of values
and people who people who are destroying
private property destroying cop cars in
an uprising against what exactly against
the black police chief against a mostly
minority police force against the black
mayor against the black president
against the black attorney general
against the entirely against a city
council that is nine of 15
are black and all 15 are elected
democrats what is the uprising against
what is it seeking to achieve
i still don't see what exactly the the
riots are seeking to achieve
bottom line is this is all
it all could be boiled down to just act
like a mensch
act like a human being honestly it's not
a useful it's not useful to riot it's
not useful to break things it's not
useful to throw rocks at people
and the idea that we're supposed to sort
of correlate your level of outrage
i'm going to stick to the 30 seconds
yeah the last time the last sentence
the idea that we're supposed to
correlate your level of outrage with a
certain level of justification in other
words the more outraged you are and more
angry you are the more justified you
must be is absolute nonsense
is there is there a line that you draw
for yourself or is there some
some way that you interpret statistical
disparity
and you determine that that is not a
racial disparity it's something else
well we can return to it that's okay too
ben do you want to yes
it's it's called evidence of racism when
there is no evidence of racism
it's probably not racism when there is
actual evidence of racism it's probably
racism
and the fact that everybody jumps from
there's inequality and therefore there
is inequity
just because there's inequality does not
mean there was inequity but there has to
be racism you can't be
considerate of racism no no no no no no
i'm just saying that i don't know which
animal or maybe maybe we're talking
about
dogs or something i'm talking about
human beings and i'm like
human beings are most likely going to
have racial prejudices i'm just so sorry
i i'm just so sorry i i don't know i i i
don't come in
i want to ask you a question so your
default your default is that when there
is no evidence racism is the deciding
factor
no no no it's not saying that i'm just
saying that uh that you're going to have
sexes you're going to have racist
you're gonna have all this stuff i mean
i'm just saying that i agree it exists
but the problem that i'm seeing
and this is the problem with the general
conversation is that there's no solution
in simply saying
there's racism out there how does that
solve anything i mean when you talk
about there's institutional racism
what does that mean show me a law that
is racist in intent
and we will agree show me a police
officer who commits a racist act like we
saw in south carolina
right where a police officer shot a
black man running away and it was
obviously unjustified
and i will agree but you nee the the the
idea that you can craft a narrative
based on no
racism because it just must be somewhere
out there in the ether that doesn't
solve problems for anybody and creates
more problems for people because now
they grow up in a milieu
in an environment where they are told
that every obstacle they face is from
some shadowy nameless faceless group
who's out to get them simply because of
the color of their skin they'll never
succeed in that environment
so my question is about race and culture
so while i agree with you that when you
look at white america it's silly to say
that the majority of white americans
are actively trying to prevent you from
getting to where you want to be
i'm east indian and i have definitely
experienced some racism but i never felt
as though it keeps indians from
succeeding
so i do think there's a cultural
component that supersedes the color of
your skin
but i also think that it's naive to say
that it just so happens that the same
minority groups that have been
historically oppressed
happen to have cultures that are less
conducive to success
i believe that environment can create
culture uh can you acknowledge the
historical reasonings that led
that these so-called unsuccessful
cultures uh and not put blame on these
minority groups
uh i know that in your heart i don't
think you're a racist person uh but in
my
in my opinion uh to blame people for
their failure for their cultural
failures without taking
into considering historical uh the
history in general conceals a lack of
empathy and
sort of hints at racism okay so i'll
fight back on the last point that
that you know there's anything to do
with empathy or racism here um but
i fully agree with you like 100 not like
90 like 100
i think the bad cultures are generally
the result of bad things that have
happened in the past or bad modes of
thought that have prevailed over time
so for example uh there's a great book
by thomas soule
uh called uh black rednecks and white
liberals uh and that book
essentially suggests that a lot of the
pathologies that exist about single
motherhood for example in the black
community
or high rates of violence are actually
outgrowths of
a slave and post-slave culture that was
imposed
by a white society that didn't bother
with policing that didn't in
that didn't care about inculcating
morals or virtues in
in slaves obviously they actually
actively fought against it because they
didn't want that to
happen um and so there was an active
fight from a symbol against assimilation
by white people and that created
an underground culture that's really bad
and that existed in parts of white
america too it exists in appalachia
so yes i think bad cultures have nothing
to do with race
uh i don't think that just because this
is why i'm saying i don't know why
borders on racism to say the cultures
are bad like some cultures are bad some
cultures are good and that has nothing
to do with race
charles murray wrote an entire book
called coming apart about pathologies in
white communities
uh that that are really destructive so
bad cultures do arise
very often from historical circumstances
including historical discrimination
what i say is that today there's nothing
preventing an individual
from superseding the culture in which
you grew up and making good decisions
in the free country somebody's going to
have to break this chain somebody's
going to have to break the cycle
and so am i going to bl i don't care if
you want to if you want to
say that that the pathology that exists
in the black community uh black inner
city community of
high rates of single motherhood and
violence for example um or
lack of institutional wealth uh that
that is a result of historic racism i'm
fine with you saying that i don't have
any problem with that i'm not talking
about historical races when i talk about
white privilege
i'm talking about right now the idea
that there's a superstructure of rules
and laws
that are preventing you from succeeding
or a culture that is trying to keep you
down
i don't think that's the case so the
question becomes if you are here let's
say let's say that on average
the culture in white america uh or
with regard to single motherhood to take
an example uh is is here right because
there's less single mother in the white
community than the black community
and in the black community it's it's
here because it's 70 single motherhood
rate and the white
community is 40 okay so the question is
before thanks to racism and thanks to
discrimination there was a cap on the
black community that was here
and they couldn't get past it okay now
the ceiling's been removed so what do
you as an individual black person do
to change your life and i don't think
it's helpful and in fact i think it's
actually quite hurtful
to spend an enormous amount of time
talking about the legacy of
discrimination and racism instead of
talking about what can you do
right now to fix your problem now this
is a general issue that i have in all of
my relationships my when my wife comes
to me
and she says there's a problem in my
life before we even have the
conversation i say to her
is this a listening conversation or is
this you want me to fix that
conversation
and i think that when it comes to
politics there should be far fewer
listening conversations like i want you
to tell me about all the crap that's
happening because i don't care
i mean i care but it doesn't but now the
question is what you're gonna do
right that's a much more important
conversation because we only have five
minutes together
is that five minutes gonna be spent on
all the terrible things that happened
which i fully agree with that i would
have fought if i were there but i wasn't
right are we gonna spend five minutes
talking about all the terrible things
that happened to blacks and jews and
gays and women and
and hispanics in the united states are
we gonna talk about right now what you
can do to succeed because i don't think
that the rules are holding you back
so i've never ever at any point
suggested that there's not been historic
discrimination against black people or
even that
current day poverty is at least in part
and outgrowth of that historic
discrimination what i have suggested is
that if you're using that historic
discrimination as a reason why you are
not
as an individual human being becoming
more income mobile
and not making good decisions no one is
making the call for you right now as an
individual to get that girl pregnant
and that's that's the argument that i'm
making
sure yeah um so i guess
like would you like so don't you you
have to admit though that
between different races and different
cultures there are there are different
levels of success and
there's definitely you would expect that
somebody who grows up with
with uh with less with being able less
to succeed you you would
you would expect that that would happen
in certain insert communities and
certainly right that's why they're
called pathologies of culture yeah for
sure
i mean if you grew up in a worse
situation than somebody else who grew up
in a better situation of course you're
gonna grow up
having obstacles that that other person
has to overcome but that doesn't mean
that that other person number one
victimized you
right there's no one in america today
for example who's enslaved a black
person
that i know of or if they have to be in
jail um i'm sure that nobody in this
room right none of the young white
people in this room
were alive during the times of jim crow
so the question is
do we take away from the white people in
this room to rectify historic injustices
or do we recognize that history is
filled with historic injustices
and now we're going to have to find a
way to overcome those obstacles together
without redistributing income for
example now i have called for
movements for example for uh for
companies to go into inner cities
and make a deal with students in inner
cities and say to them listen you get
good grades and we'll pay for your
college and then you come afterward and
you work for us for three years to pay
off that debt
i think there are things that we can do
in the private sector this is why i
think religious communities are so
important
i'm not against charity i'm not against
us as individuals going out and helping
people
what i am against is the idea that the
government can fix this problem because
the government cannot fix historic
inequity
although the government can do is set
the rules at at an equal level equal law
equal you know equal judgment under law
equal justice under law
is the only way that we're ever going to
approach anything that looks like a fair
society there's no such thing as a fair
society where the government plays god
and gives them to others and takes from
others
so would you would you say that you
basically we should
like other people who are not you know
in an oppressed state they should
they should wait and wait for other
people to pull themselves up uh
do you think that's how we should solve
it or do you think there is i think
every culture in american history every
individual in american history who has
succeeded
has had a combination of people who help
them out not in the government people
who help them out
and their own capacity to bootstrap it
and when my
great-grandparents got here they were
dirt poor and didn't speak english
uh great great grandparents got here
they're dirt poor and didn't speak
english this is true for virtually
everybody in the room right at some
point somebody came over here and they
were dirt poor and didn't speak english
and that doesn't mean that on a
generational level people are going to
go from from zero to
um but it does mean that we're gonna
need to move in the right direction as
opposed to sitting around and talking
about historic injustice all day
because that doesn't get anything done
so i'd have this experience as a
missionary in connecticut
um on the drive between west hartford to
hartford
where everyone went from it's actually
hartford west hartford
where everyone went from usually poor
not white
and then two blocks later like like mini
mansions everywhere everyone's white
um i feel like left has done a really
good job
i'm kind of taking this kind of general
feeling of like oh look there's
you know people are poor and
no one's white over there and then two
blocks later like everyone's white
everyone's rich they've done a really
good job of kind of taking that
that message and turning it into into
systemic racism
right yes i was wondering if you thought
there was anything
conservatives could do as far as
messaging
to to kind of still address the problem
but
but doing it in a conservative way we're
like sure so i think
yeah so jordan i think that there's a a
category error that has been
actively promulgated by the media and by
the political left and you mentioned the
category error here and that is there
are two
cross-cutting distinctions that we've
mentioned in this conversation already
the cross-cutting distinction between
poor and rich and the cross-cutting
distinction between black and white
one of these right is not the cause
right so what the left has done is
they've said
that the distinctions are essentially
the same they've conflated the two poor
equals black rich equals white right
this is something that joe biden himself
has said
right joe biden gaffed a couple months
ago and he said
you know there's a difference between
being rich and being black
right which is which is an incredible
statement there are lots of rich black
people in america
and there are lots of poor white people
in america yeah so what so
because black people in the united
states are disproportionately poorer
than
white people in the united states
although asian people in the united
states are disproportionately richer
than either one of those groups by the
way
because people conflate the
cross-cutting distinctions between they
say because they basically argue that
poor equals black and rich equals white
first of all that's kind of racist
because it ain't true but two it's
actually yeah it's ignoring the real
problem which is how do we get poor
people to be richer
the bottom line is that the recipe for
success is the same for everyone in the
united states
you make responsible decisions you don't
have babies out of wedlock you finish
high school
if you go to college try to major in in
something where you're actually gonna
make money on the other end like for
example you'll see people cite
statistics that black college graduates
don't earn as much as white college
graduates
that doesn't adjust for major if you
major in in a soft
study a liberal arts study you're not
gonna make as much money as if you major
in stem
which is why white college graduates
earn less than asian american college
graduates for example
right they're just decisions and so what
i said in that clip and it's right
obviously which is why you see the the
people who i'm talking to one is a
member of the local naacp
one's member of the seattle stranger
right you see these people go from
laughing to being kind of chastened
a little bit in the clip is it is not
arguable
that pathologies of poverty like single
motherhood have nothing to do with race
when the single motherhood rate in the
black community went from 20 to 1960 to
well over 70
today that is going to have some
significant downstream effect
when the high school dropout rate
differential between high school black
students and high school white students
is significant that's going to have
significant downstream effect what does
that have to do with race the answer is
it doesn't have anything to do with race
i don't think that racing culture
have to be interrelated nor nor should
they be i mean i wouldn't say that it is
quote unquote black culture to
not value education there are plenty of
black americans who value education
extraordinarily highly
i think that there's there are certain
pathologies that exist
in poor communities black or white that
are common across
those communities now they may not exist
in the same proportions in those
communities
but that has nothing to do with race and
everything to do with culture right
they're areas of white appalachia where
education is not valued particularly
highly j.d vance talks about this
in in hillbilly elegy the the
pathologies of poverty that exist
cross-racially are the same and then
it's just a question of how often they
exist
in particular communities regardless of
race so pathologies of poverty include
not valid valuing education enough
such that your kids are not spending a
lot of time on homework or
not having fathers in the home such that
you have two parents who are available
to help read with your kids
pathologies of poverty exist high
include
high crime include again lack of fathers
in the home means that very often young
men
tend to congregate in gangs right those
are pathologies of poverty
right all those pathologies are not
unique to the black community they may
exist as proportionally in particular
black communities but that doesn't mean
that that's because of the race the
police arrest black americans at higher
rates than white americans
they also arrest white americans at a
higher rate than asian americans
the question isn't what proportion of a
population is arrested
the question is whether the police are
targeting a population by
race for arrest if the police are merely
arresting people who commit crimes
and the crimes are committed
disproportionately by race
that is not the police's fault that's
the police doing their job just before
president biden's inauguration
the justice department's bureau of
justice statistics issued a report
designed to answer
whether the police were arresting people
at disproportionate rates
based on crime reports if 20 out of 100
crime reports named black suspect
but 60 of police arrests were black
suspects for example
that would be presumptively
discriminatory
if 60 out of 100 crime reports named a
black suspect and 60 percent of police
arrests or
black suspects that would be the police
doing their job
the report concluded according to the
wall street journal that there was no
statistically significant difference by
race
between how likely people were to commit
serious violent crimes
and how likely they were to be arrested
in other words the data suggested that
police officers and sheriff's deputies
focus on criminals
actions not their race the report
compared arrest statistics with victims
reports and found no statistically
significant difference
for non-fatal violent crimes for example
35 of reported offenders were black
33 of arrests were black americans
this does not look like systemic racism
so there's a theory out there
the theory is that racial disparities in
the united states are almost entirely
due to
so-called white privilege the idea here
is that america is a country that was
built
for the exclusive preserve of white men
and that white men have dominated ever
since and therefore every disparity
between racial groups any statistical
disparity between racial groups can
therefore be blamed on the history of
the united states
and more specifically on the united
states right now because obviously some
disparity can be blamed on the history
of the united states to pretend that
discrimination hasn't existed
in the united states would be foolish of
course discrimination has of course
discrimination against black people is
rampant i mean there's slavery there's
jim crow of course that's true
but the question is whether white
privilege right now
is what is causing continued disparity
between particular groups
this is so counterproductive it's beyond
belief
if you believe that protests are
legitimate against police brutality why
in the world would you start justifying
riots like people looting targets and
such
the narrative that black americans are
under threat from police broadly
speaking across america is just not true
it's not a reality that does not mean
that there are
more confrontations between black
americans and police because police
are usually in high crime neighborhoods
and unfortunately there are a lot of
high crime neighborhoods
that happen to be black that is that's
that's a tragedy and it's and the only
way
that that's going to be solved with more
police not fewer police is with crime
rates going down not crime rates going
up
the the phrase black lives matter should
be relatively uncontroversial because
again it is true that black lives matter
and i think everybody agrees that black
lives matter it's the implication of the
phrase that people are objecting to
the implication being that they're a
bunch of people who think they don't
right the the id you then you generally
don't chance uncontroversial things
right people don't go out in the streets
and chant the sky is blue right people
don't go out on the streets
and chant we love children right like
you don't chant
uncontroversial things so when you when
you chant black lives matters the
implication is that there are a bunch of
people
who don't believe that black lives
matters and that's what people are
objecting to that's why people will say
all lives matter
not because they are saying that black
lives matter less but because they're
saying
right we agree that black lives matter
just as every other life matters
so you know i think that the implication
of the black lives matter movement which
is more than just the slogan uh the the
the slogan itself
fine but again the implication is that
black people are under existential
threat in the united states and there's
a vast group of people in the united
states who don't care if black people
are under
under existential threat that whole
implication is what people object to if
it were just
you know an obvious if it was just an
obvious truism that black lives matter i
don't think it would even be
controversial
that people are chanting it if you are a
writer if you are looter
you're a human scum you're doing nothing
positive for society
what you're acting on is not quote
unquote justified anger your piece of
crap you're a piece of crap and you
should be arrested you should be
prosecuted business owners should defend
their businesses
this is sheer unbelievable garbage and
the failure of government to perform its
single function
which is to protect the law abiding that
failure of government is catastrophic
i'm talking from local governments to
state governments to the federal
government the lack
of ability of the government to do the
one thing it is supposed to do right
this government that's supposed to
provide you everything that you could
possibly need provide you privileges
from the top
instead it can't even protect you in
your own cities
this government